Hillary Clinton has come out with a new
book yeah
I'm sooo excited yeah yeah it's making a
lot of news because they revealed some
details today about her book yeah in her
new book Hillary Clinton calls Donald
Trump this is true a creep who made her
skin crawl
creep he made her skin crawl
yeah when he heard this Trump smiled and
said I still got it
[Applause]
he's probably every morning like a
little and then he looks in the mirror
and he's like hey creep
last night President Trump spoke at a
rally in Arizona really fired up his
supporters really fired up his
supporters yeah he opened his speech by
saying this is a quote our movement is a
movement built on love yeah yeah in
other words he started with his best
joke that's what you do misterx strong I
didn't know I'm glad he's straight
nothing at yesterday's Trump rally the
crowd was chanting CNN sucks
CNN suck that's some of that love yeah
yeah yeah
no crowd chanting CNN sucks the answer
yeah man you do not want to hear what
they had to say about the Science
Channel that was ugly okay yeah yeah
really nasty yeah
you try you try to rhyme evolution I
[Music]
just did my head last night this is true
president Trump said of his critics this
is a quote I went to better schools and
they did that was a better student and
they were I live in a bigger more
beautiful apartment and I live in the
White House - yeah yeah then someone
handed Trump a fidgets spinner and he
quieted right down
I'm the best at this I bet if he was
with someone else with a physics printer
he'd just be gone if you like with a
child and he'd be going faster yeah yeah
totally totally beat you it's being
reported that President Trump is no
longer speaking to Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell no longer
speaking to him yeah
Yap on hearing this Melania when Sam
McConnell and said teach me master what
else is going on other news in the world
yeah in Saudi Arabia a 14-year old boy
was detained for dancing to the Macarena
you know I don't say this often but I'm
gonna sign with the Saudi government on
this one
I think anyone yes you taint away I'm
Charlie well yeah detain away and you
see you see a kid dancing to a hit from
1996 yeah put him in jail take the
rights away this is weird some parents
in California are mad that a
kindergarten teacher read their kids a
book about transgenderism yeah yeah it
was the dr. Seuss classic Cat in the Hat
who identifies as a dog
then I understand there's a guy here and
a very attractive woman I present my
nipple
the woman recoils in horror and the guy
leaps out she actually covered
[Music]
it's not what I was going for there
you